when you buy a US Treasury security
you're essentially giving a loan to the
US federal government and just as an
example here I have a US Treasury
security in which it says that the owner
of this this piece of paper will be paid
one thousand dollars in one year so if
you buy this from the treasurer maybe
you're buying it from someone else but
let's just say that the government is
issuing them right now let's say you buy
it for let's say you buy it for nine
hundred and fifty dollars and the
government will give you will give you
this security right over here now fast
forward fast forward one year fast
forward one year you're holding this
security and what happens so you know
all that stuff is written there what
happens a year later well written on the
security and I've simplified it just for
this example it says the old the holder
of the security will get a thousand
dollars so at this point the US
government has to give you has to give
you one thousand dollars has to give you
one thousand dollars so when you look at
just the money flows it's pretty clear
that you just lend the money you gave
them nine hundred fifty dollars now and
then a year later they give you one
thousand dollars and if you wanted to
put this in terms that you normally
associate with borrowing money in terms
of how much interest did you get well
you lent nine hundred fifty dollars and
you got back a thousand so let's think
about it this way let's get a calculator
out
so one thousand divided by nine hundred
and fifty one thousand divided by nine
hundred and fifty is equal to 1.0 five
just to round at one point oh five three
so you've got one point oh five three or
one hundred and five point three percent
of your money back so let me put it this
way so this is this is one hundred five
point three percent of money lent of
money given of money given to the
government or another way to think about
it is you've got a five point three
percent interest or if you you you lent
your money out at a annual interest of
5.3 percent you got your money back plus
you got five point three percent after
year so you could imagine if all of a
sudden many people want to buy this this
government security and now the price
goes up instead of being nine hundred
and fifty dollars let's imagine that it
is now nine hundred and eighty dollars
what is the implicit yield that the
person would now get on it well we get
the calculator back out here so if you
pay so you're going to get a thousand
dollars and if you pay it in nine
hundred eighty instead of nine hundred
fifty then a year later when you get the
thousand dollars back that'll only be a
hundred two percent of your money so in
that situation it would be one hundred
and two percent of your money so when
the nine hundred fifty dollar price
you're essentially lending the money the
government money at five point three
percent and at nine hundred eighty
dollars you're lending the government
money at two percent and I'm doing this
to show you a point when the price of
the Treasury security goes up has
happened in this case the yield the
interest that you're getting on your
loan goes down because then I either
situation you're going to just get a
thousand dollars back if you land nine
hundred eighty and get a thousand
dollars back you're only getting two
percent on your money if you lend nine
hundred fifty and get thousand dollars
back you get five point three percent
and so this is what people are talking
about when they say if Treasury prices
go up if Treasury prices go up then the
yield goes down so if there's more
demand for Treasuries the interest rate
on Treasuries will go down in the next
video we'll talk about how this might
change for Treasuries of different
maturity dates